joining us now is retired Admiral sandy
Winnefeld former vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff he's a CBS News
military and homeland security analyst
Admiral good morning two big questions
that we've been trying to parse this
morning are what did I Ron intend with
this attack and how my the u.s. responds
let's take the first part of that more
than a dozen ballistic missiles this is
a US base in Iraq what's the intention
of the Iranian military well first this
was a very very carefully calibrated
attack on the part of Iran first what
did they use they used increasingly
accurate ballistic missiles either the
chyme one or the Fateh 110 which other
than those that might have gone astray
which always happens probably hit pretty
close to what their targets were so the
second thing is what were their targets
this is a big sprawling airbase mostly
desert they could have targeted these
missiles into remote areas to avoid any
possibility that an American could be
killed or they might have done what we
would have done and that is perhaps
target aircraft on the ramp but not
barracks or places where there would be
a lot of people and then to your
question the third thing is what were
they trying to accomplish well there
were really four key audiences here the
first is the United States hey we can
hit you guys and by the way we didn't
hurt anybody so please don't start a war
with us that we would lose second
audience of course is the internal
Iranian audience and they can say
anything they want to to that audience
we did this hard revenge we killed 80
Americans which of course isn't true but
they have that internal message the
third audience is the international
community hey we did this legally in
self-defense so please don't come after
us there and the fourth audience of
course is the regional audience please
don't help the Americans retaliate for
this and by the way why don't you kick
them out of the region so it was very
carefully calibrated and we'll see what
happens next
if you were if you were advising the
president at this point what should
happen next you think well there are
three major sort of chunky possibilities
here one would be a disproportionate
response which the president alluded to
in previous days but didn't you know
sign up for necessarily and I don't
think that's what he will do it's
certainly not what I would advise
the next would be a proportional
response where you might just go after
in self-defense some of the missile
sites the storage handling facilities
command and control but there are a lot
of problems associated with that option
as well
the third is essentially to let this go
and underneath you sort of have a tacit
agreement with Iran that says we got
ours you got yours and by the way we
think we might have gotten the better
end of this thing and above the line you
can tell the international community hey
look how restrained we were and look how
much of a menace this Iranian country is
and why don't you climb on board with
sanctions and the like and at the same
time send a very strong message to Iran
that says proxy war is over that's how
this whole thing started we're not going
to let you have your proxies hit us
anymore and we'll go after them if you
do and we'll also go after you sandy you
have been in the room you touched on it
briefly with with Anthony's question
you've been in the room with top
security officials excuse me when
they're having these discussions
what is that conversation like what
exactly are you all what are they saying
to each other at this point interesting
question here your perspective because
you're the only one here that knows what
that's like sure
generally these meetings would start
with a review by the intelligence
community of what they think happened
why it happened and what's coming next
and then you would have various people
around the table State Department would
provide diplomatic options and what
they're hearing from the the rest of the
international community some of the
implications for some of the things we
might do of course you would hear from
the military from the Department of
Vince on what various options would be
for some kind of a response or and how
we're protecting our own troops in the
region and after all of that is vetted
it really comes down to the person at
the end of the table who has the
loneliest job on the planet
and at who has to integrate all of this
information and then decide on a
response and a strategy going forward
Admiral is your sense that the Iranians
are done after this attack because they
seem to send conflicting signals the
supreme leader said it's not over the
Foreign Minister said this was
proportionate and we concluded our
response well I think Michael Morell
said it very well
and that is I believe the overt piece of
this is over at least as far as the
Iranians are concerned but the proxy
piece the covert piece remains to be
seen I do think that the proxies in Iraq
do want a piece of this action and so
it's not a good time to be complacent
about self defense for our troops but
that's the real question mark I think is
as Michael pointed out where do we go
with the nuclear program and where do we
go with covert action from Iran all
right bringing us inside the Situation
Room there Admiral Winnefeld thank you
very much
you